is every movie about sex and violence no
every movie is not about sex of violence
every movie is about identity Who am I
how do I know I'm really here
why should I do I put up with what I put
up with but there is a lot of sex of
violence in movies and appropriately so
as I've said in the past and the number
of occasions it's a safe place so we are
violent and sexual creatures human
beings just take a look at the
newspapers this morning or any morning
it's hard to not to imagine that this is
not the darkest day and we talk about
the dark ages I mean how can they be
darker age than this with people being
burned alive and then girls and hundreds
of girls kids to have been abducted and
carried off by deranged terrorists and
and all of the horror that that we're
we're all too familiar familiar with we
are violent creatures and I really
believe dramatic narratives are kind of
a therapy a way to practice to work out
these lethal aspects of our nature in a
safe place the movie theater and you
know Aristotle in the poetics talks
about purgation purging this these
violent aspects from us there can't be
any doubt that that's the central part
of the you know the nature of women a
man is darkness and rage and and
destruction happily there is the other
side of that too this is why I rejoice
to be on a college campus like UCLA
where the affirming stuff comes through
the healing the the beauty the
the joy that can be had is available cuz
life is both of both of those things
here's my I'm a new grandpa here's my my
daughter Etta our little a little grants
and imagine that I actually show that to
you the only reason I do that is to
indicate that when I see them and all of
her friends here will have them babies
now and it's it's wonderful is nothing
my only regret in life is that I didn't
have like eleven children we only have
the two and they were so inconsiderate
as to grow up and become adults on us
but the point is I see my little
grandson Cooper and the will is right
with the world there is joy there is
beauty there is love there is healing
there's warmth there's there's there's
nourishment there's all of that good
stuff too and the there's something
biological and narratives to help us
purge that darker aspect of our of our
lives and that's why I think there's so
much sex and violence in in film we
drawn to conflict we like to when our
little daughter before she was old
enough to be mother and she was just a
little kid if if we were in a restaurant
and an argument broke out somewhere
she'd gone over to look at it you know I
mean just like you slow down to look at
a car wreck do I do that I do why don't
we do it because I'm some kind of a
pervert a loony
maybe so but the real reason I do it is
I'm human I'm interested in conflict I
am politically I love to listen to
people I disagree with and I'm bored
listening to people I agree with we like
conflict we need conflict and
confrontation and where does that reside
in life but in sex just no small extent
and certainly in in violence so it's
absolutely appropriate that there that
there is sex and violence and film and
again it was not invented in Hollywood
this goes back to the earliest
storytelling the the earliest stories we
have array you know from the ancient
Greeks Oedipus and Eliot
in the Odyssey and the Iliad but also at
abyss Rex you know not much later those
plays those Greek plays they were blood
baths Medea murders our own children in
a jealous rage this isn't some tabloid
throwaway cheapo movie this is one of
the great classics of the world
literature Medea
Richard the third murders his own
nephews their boys 9 and 11 he doesn't
even suspect them of having done
anything wrong they're just in the way
you know they're in the it's wrong place
wrong time the you know with the
succession Hamlet ends with nine corpses
on the stage some of them have been run
through on swords some of them have been
poisoned nobody wants to see the village
of the happy nice people this is say
again what what what excites people is
not serenity and and calm and everybody
getting along being uplifted but ugly
bloody stuff and again the reason we
were attracted to all of that is is
because it's part of the human condition
and it's actually I think an
evolutionary and a biological necessity
for us I believe that the first movie
theaters were those caves in Altamira or
Lesko the the famous European caves
where they discovered these cave
paintings of these antelopes and so on
with multiple pairs of legs as if they
were in motion
remember these these were painted in
opaque places you know in caves where
there was absolutely no light so how did
they do that well they had light they
had torches that were fueled by animal
tallow you know like like fat and you
can imagine it was a flickering kind of
an image you know so there were these
flickering they had multiple exits oh it
looked like they were moving Disney
actually done years ago taking those
paintings and actually animated them
we've held the pair of feet in this
frame put them back in the next one take
them out in the next one put them back
on the one after that and they really
seem to be running so what was going on
here these were the animals that were
hunted by the people who live there the
cave civilization that created those
paintings they hunted those animals and
the reason they hunted them was their
lives depended on it they use their meat
for protein without it they would starve
but they didn't just use the meat they
used these skins for wardrobe and for
residences you know they built tents out
of out of these things to protect
themselves and so on now how does a
human being you know a cave person who
might be about five feet tall bring down
an antelope you know with that his horns
and so on and the answer is first of all
by cooperating with other other people
which is unique to human beings the way
we were able to but we've been able to
achieve through cooperation imagine
going to the moon for goodness sake what
an achievement that is because nobody
could do that on his own it's got to be
a team of people and likewise on your
own you can't bring down with a stick
and antelope that's 300 pounds but you
can if you organize but in order to do
that you know you have a bunch of people
and and some of them are chasing them
and scaring them and this way then is a
you and a bunch of your comrades you're
standing there with this with the spikes
you can and again your life depends not
a sport your life depends on life of
your children depend upon your
succeeding at this what else do you need
to do you need to overcome the fear and
the I mean imagine what would you do if
you had a sword and there was an
antelope coming you do a turn and you'd
run well that's what I would do
so we
they were rehearsing they were like
watching these images and pretending
that they were they were real you know
herds of antelope coming at them and in
that way they sort of they realize they
survived they had that experience they
had that emotion that fear but they were
okay now in the real world they can you
know confront an animal like that and
experience the fear but not run now
we're not chasing antelopes anymore so
we're not afraid of that so what are we
what are we what are one of the real
dangers I'll tell you what the biggest
danger in my life and I'm about to
embrace it again and then it's driving
home tonight 13 miles to Silver Lake I
mean that's a serious danger I'm
counting on a thousand people to stay on
this the line you know I'm trusting that
they'll do that
what's another real danger it's not as
much as a danger as it used to be but
it's a big danger and it scares
everybody and that is violent crime as
movies have become much much more
violent crime is actually plunged in
this in this nation I'm not saying it's
because of the violence in the movies
but certainly the increase I mean my god
you look at something like Walking Dead
Breaking Bad Sopranos air is the kind of
violence you never ever have imagined in
the media and yet it hasn't caused crime
it's crime seems to have have gone down
so what are we afraid of what's the
danger in our lives automobiles in a
very practical sense in crime so what do
you what are you looking at in also
disease so go to the movies is going to
be movies about diseases movies about
car crashes is a big thing in movies and
car chases and certainly crime we're
just like those cave people in their
caves except that it's IMAX and comes
with popcorn
you